on a un exemple encore plus proche de
chez nous raïs badaoui j'ai eu
l'occasion de rencontrer sa femme ses
enfants vivent à sherbrooke
c'est un 10 et c'est complètement bavard
d'imposer des peines de flagellation
comme ça il faut que le canada continue
à suivre un modèle qu'on a déjà suivi
regarder le bilan des droits humains
avant de conclure une vente mesure
harper ne le fait plus merci monsieur
duceppe
je les y tantôt il faut interrompre les
ventes l'arabie saoudite riyal à corps
du jeune homme qui sera décapité 5 royal
les rails badaoui aussi on doit
intervenir on doit dénoncer également
l'élection représente l arabie saoudite
à la tête de la commission des droits de
la personne aux nations unies ce système
aux criques le délire quelqu'un à d'un
tel pays à la tête de ce qui devrait
être un comité qui s'occupe des droits
de la personne
on a on a toujours dénoncé ces incidents
comme ça ce traitement comme ça on est
pour les droits de la personne à travers
la planète
c'est la même chose que le cas de mr
badaoui à nos gouvernements dénoncer ça
nous avons indiqué que nous accepterons
monsieur badawi qui n'a pas citoyen
canadien à n'importe quel moment
mais ce n'est pas juste de punir des
travailleurs d'une usine à landon proulx
ça on ce n'est pas de gros bon sens
monsieur trudeau le canada toujours pu
faire plus pour influencer la situation
dans le monde en travaillant avec les
autres pays or depuis dix ans on alterne
tellement perdu que tout simplement de
dénoncer ces plus acide nous devons de
travailler avec nos alliés pour exiger à
l'international que les pays commencent
à se comporter de façon vous respectez
beaucoup plus les droits humains et le
canada malheureusement n'a plus la voix
qu'on avait avant que monsieur harper
devienne premier ministre
merci monsieur madame mais oui c'est
clair que nous avons à l'est avec l'aso
l'arabie saudite et ignorer le bilan des
bus le doigt humaine et ignorait le le
bus dont le
dont le pays est en même temps nous
avons vendu des armements vers l'art vie
se dit c'est affreux et on va le
terminer